Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux,
ça vous dirait de faire rimer
vacances et science ?
Alors c'est parti pour mon top 5 des lieux scientifiques à visiter cet été.
1. La Chaîne des Puys.
Nul besoin d'aller au bout du monde
pour admirer de superbes volcans.
La chaîne des Puys en Auvergne en compte
80 sur près de 32 kilomètres.
Ce sont des volcans monogéniques.
Cela signifie qu'ils se sont formés à
l'occasion d'une seule et unique éruption.
La plus récente a eu lieu il y a 8500 ans.
Les hommes en ont été témoins.
Les volcanologues n'excluent pas
la possibilité que certains d'entre eux
se réveillent un beau matin.
Mais je vous rassure,
ils sont sous haute surveillance.
Le plus emblématique de tous,
c'est le Puy de Dôme.
Il culmine à 1465 mètres d'altitude.
Là haut, la vue est imprenable
sur la chaîne des Puys.
On peut y accéder à pied
par deux chemins de randonnée
qui ont été aménagés à cet effet.
Le sentier des Muletiers
et le chemin des chèvres.
Les moins courageux
se contenteront d'embarquer
à bord du Panoramique des Dômes.
C'est un petit train touristique qui offre
une vue à 360 degrés lors de la montée.
Je l'ai pris, c'est magnifique.
Tiens, à ce propos.
Nous avons réalisé une vidéo sur la chaîne des Puys,
elle est ici.
Avec un peu de chance.
Les lève-tôt pourront observer au sommet
du Puy de Dôme son spectre de Brocken.
C'est un phénomène physique
assez surprenant lorsque le soleil n'est
pas encore levé sur l'horizon,
l'ombre de la montagne
se projette sur les nuages.
Si cette ombre n'est pas trop éloignée,
on peut voir sa propre silhouette
dans le brouillard
avec plusieurs auréoles colorées.
Un spectacle bien mérité
après une bonne randonnée matinale.
2. La grotte Chauvet.
Après avoir tutoyé les cimes,
plongeons 25 mètres sous terre
du côté de Vallon-Pont-d'Arc,
en Ardèche.
C'est ici que Jean-Marie Chauvet
a découvert une étonnante
grotte souterraine en 1994.
Il en est donc "l'inventeur".
Eh oui, c'est le nom que l'on donne
aux petits chanceux qui découvrent
une grotte.
Et le moins que l'on puisse dire,
c'est que Jean-Marie Chauvet
a fait une sacrée trouvaille.
Comme Lascaux,
sa grotte est ornée de peintures.
Mais ce qui la rend unique au monde,
c'est l'époque
à laquelle elles ont été réalisées,
il y a plus de 30000 ans,
durant une période appelée : Aurignacien.
Au départ, cette estimation
réalisée au carbone 14 a déconcerté
de nombreux spécialistes.
En effet,
jamais des peintures rupestres aussi
anciennes n'avaient été mises au jour.
À titre de comparaison, le bestiaire
de Lascaux ne date que de 18000 ans.
Les dessins de Chauvet n'ont rien à envier
aux chefs d'oeuvre de sa petite sœur.
Ses parois sont couvertes de lions,
de chevaux, de rhinocéros et de mammouths.
La plupart de ces dessins ont été réalisés
à l'ocre rouge.
C'est le tout premier pigment
utilisé par l'homme pour peindre.
D'autres ont été composés à l'aide
de charbon de bois,
l'ancêtre du fusain
que nous utilisons aujourd'hui.
Malheureusement,
la grotte Chauvet en tant que tel n'est
plus accessible au public
suite à une série d'éboulements.
Mais sur le modèle de Lascaux,
sa réplique à l'identique a été construite
juste à côté.
C'est la plus grande réplique de grotte
au monde.
3. Le triangle noir du Quercy.
Après avoir goûté à l'obscurité
des grottes,
on n'est pas fâché de revoir le ciel.
Eh bien justement, parlons-en du ciel.
Direction un petit coin de France
où il est si pur qu'il
permet d'observer les étoiles
comme nulle part ailleurs.
Lorsqu'en 2002, une carte de la qualité
des ciels nocturnes en France est publiée.
Un triangle noir apparaît au dessus
du parc régional du Quercy.
C'est la zone de plus faible pollution
lumineuse de France métropolitaine.
Elle se situe entre Rocamadour
et la vallée du Célé.
La pureté du ciel y est rendue possible
grâce à l'action
des habitants des 39 communes alentours.
Ils s'astreignent
à éteindre les feux autour de minuit.
Résultat dans ce sanctuaire céleste,
la lumière nocturne
est entièrement naturelle.
Elle laisse apparaître des étoiles
qui sont invisibles ailleurs.
C'est le cas du bulbe de la Voie lactée.
Cette région du ciel
est très riche en étoiles, en nébuleuses
et en poussières d'étoiles.
Le spectacle est à couper le souffle.
Pour en faire profiter le plus grand nombre.
Le parc du Quercy a ouvert plusieurs sites
d'observation.
Et si vous êtes novice, en astronomie,
pas de panique,
des clubs du coin organisent
des sorties pédagogiques à la nuit tombée
pour observer les étoiles.
Ceux qui seront en famille ou entre amis
trouveront à leur disposition
des logements équipés de télescopes.
Histoire
d'admirer le ciel depuis sa fenêtre.
Tellement romantique non ?
4. La dune du Pilat.
Non, nous ne sommes pas au Sahara,
mais en Nouvelle-Aquitaine,
à l'entrée du bassin d'Arcachon.
Entre l'océan Atlantique
et une gigantesque forêt de pins, trône
la majestueuse dune du Pilat.
C'est la dune de sable
la plus haute d'Europe.
Elle culmine actuellement
à un peu plus de 102 mètres et s'étale sur
presque trois kilomètres de long
et plus de 600 mètres de large.
Sa taille varie au fil du temps,
en fonction du vent et de l'érosion.
Mais comment cette montagne de sable
est-elle arrivée là ?
Entre forêt et océan ?
En réalité, cette merveille géologique
ne s'est pas formée en un jour.
C'est le fruit d'un long processus
qui a débuté il y a plus de 4000 ans.
Son histoire est liée à la formation
d'un banc de sable : le banc d'Arguin.
Il est situé au large,
à quinze minutes de la dune, en bateau.
Au fil des siècles,
les courants marins ont déplacé du sable.
On dit qu'ils l'ont charrié
pour former ce banc.
Ces vents d'ouest en provenance du large
arrachent à sa surface
des grains de sable
au moment de la marée basse.
Quand il est totalement à découvert.
Ces grains de sable s'envolent
alors pour se poser sur la dune
et former ce gigantesque tas de sable.
La dune est impressionnante par sa taille,
mais aussi par l'époustouflant
panorama qu'elle offre depuis son sommet.
Sur le bassin d'Arcachon.
Le phare du Cap-Ferret
et la forêt à perte de vue.
Mais pour profiter du paysage,
il faut atteindre le sommet.
Les plus vaillants effectuent la montée.
Les pieds dans le sable.
Bon courage.
La pente est de 30 à 40 degrés.
Les autres utilisent l'escalier qui est
installé chaque année au printemps.
Petit rappel le sable de la dune
reste sur la dune.
5. Pour clôturer notre périple
des meilleurs sites scientifiques.
Direction le LHC.
Large Hadron Collider.
Plutôt communément appelé en français :
accélérateur de particules.
Il se trouve à la frontière franco-suisse entre Genève et le Pays de Gex.
C'est là, à 100 mètres sous terre,
que se trouve le plus grand
et le plus puissant
accélérateur de particules au monde.
Inauguré en 2008 puis arrêté
en décembre 2018, il reprend du service
cette année.
Et la bonne nouvelle,
c'est qu'on peut le visiter.
Ce monstre de technologie se présente
sous la forme d'un tunnel de presque
27 kilomètres de circonférence, presque la moitié de la ville de Paris.
A l'intérieur, on fait tourner des
particules à des vitesses vertigineuses.
Ce sont des protons.
Ils ont la particularité d'être composés
de particules encore plus petites,
comme le fameux boson de Higgs.
Il s'agit d'une particule de matière
que les scientifiques
avaient prédit par calcul en 1964.
Le boson est resté théorique
jusqu'en 2012, année
où le LHC a annoncé l'avoir enfin détecté.
L'événement a fait la une dans le monde
entier.
Pour obtenir ce type de particules,
le LHC provoque une collision
d'une extrême violence
entre deux protons. Ils sont propulsés à une vitesse qui frôle celle de la lumière.
Autrement dit,
un peu moins de 300000 kilomètres par
seconde.
En une seule seconde, justement,
nos protons font, tenez-vous bien,
11000 fois le tour du tunnel
ça donne le tournis.
Puis ils sont projetés l'un contre l'autre
pour être désagrégés.
On analyse ensuite les débris
qui en résultent.
En repoussant encore les limites,
le LHC nous permettra peut-être
de prouver l'existence
de la matière noire,
qui composerait à elle seule
27% de l'univers.
On suppose son existence mais à ce jour,
on ne l'a toujours pas détectée.
Alors, je vous rassure,
ne vous décomposez pas.
La visite du LHC ne prévoit pas un tour
de tunnel à la vitesse de la lumière.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout.
C'est vraiment le meilleur soutien
que vous pouvez apporter à la chaîne.
Si vous avez pensé à d'autres lieux
qui mériteraient leur place dans ce top,
n'hésitez pas à les mettre en commentaire.
Ça en intéressera plus d'un, moi
le premier.
Je vous souhaite, à toutes
et à tous, d'excellentes vacances,
mais avant de partir, n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner ! À très bientôt
les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.